المدنيين من تحت الانقاض يقول نائب الرئيس
التركي انه يوجد
ما يقارب
2300 جريح هذه الاعداد ايضا ومرجحه
للارتفاع كون المدنيين والمواطنين يواصلون
التوافق الى المشافي في هذه اللحظات يؤكد
وقوع 78 هز ارتداديه يصف بعضها بالشديده
والتي تجاوزت الخمس درجات على مقياس ريختر
ويقول فؤاد نائب الرئيس التركي بان هذه
الهزات الارتداديه بالغه الاهميه وعلى
المواطنين اتخاذ الحيطه والحذر اذ انها
تمثل الخطر الاكبر في هذا الوقت بحسب
تعبيره وذلك بسبب وجود ابنيه متصدعه ابنيه
متضرره ويدعو المواطنين الى البقاء بعيدا
عن هذه الاماكن يعلن وقف الطيران المدني
اغلاق مطاري غازي عنتاب وكرمان مرعش ما
يعني ان الوصول لن يكون سهلا كذلك الى تلك
المناطق على الاقل بالنسبه للمدنيين
القادمين من مدن ثانيه او الذين يريدون
تفقد احوال عائلاتهم او ايصال المساعدات
حيث اقف هنا الان في اداره
الطوارئ تنطلق شاحنات ضخمه نسبيا على ما
يبدو انها ستنقل المساعدات الى تلك
المناطق يوجد كذلك انتشار امني وذلك بسبب
توافذ المسؤولين الى هذه المنطقه وهناك عن
ان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان سيزور
هذا المكان خلال ساعه من الان ليكون على
اتصال مباشر مع غرفه العمليات في اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التي تشرف على عمل كل
الفرق سواء في الهلال الاحمر وزاره
الداخليه القوات المسلحه التركيه وغيرها
كل الاحوال بالعوده الى اخر التطورات التي
جاء نائب الرئيس التركي يؤكد بانم المدارس
لم تتضرر كثيرا لكن اعلن عن عطله لمده
اسبوع في 10 محافظات هي التي ضربها هذا
الزلزال فجره اليوم ويقول ان الان
الاولويه في محاوله لتقليل الاضرار بمعنى
تسريع عمليات
الانقاذ انتشال المزيد من الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض بما يؤدي الى عدم ارتفاع عدد
القتلى من جانب ثاني يؤشر هنا الى الماشيه
يقول ان تلك المناطق التي تعتمد على
الماشيه وعلى الانتاج الزراعي هنالك ايضا
فرق تنطلق من وزاره الزراعه والغابات
مخصصه لاواء الحيوانات في تلك المنطقه
والتي تؤدي التي تعتبر بشكل او باخر مصدر
رزق للمدنيين المتواجدين هناك يعتبر او
يؤكد ان تركيا منطقه الزلازل تحدث فيها
زلازل وهزات من هذا النوع بين الحين الاخر
لكن المهم في هذه المرحله هو التقليل من
الاضرار تجهيز البناء التحتيه دائما
التعلم من هذه الزلازل والهزات وبناء بناء
تحتيه
جيده وقادره على الصمود امام هزات من هذا
النوع يشير هنا الى ان المباني التاريخيه
تحديدا في منطقه غازي عنتاب تعرضت لاضرار
ماديه كبيره لكن الابنيه الحديثه والتي
بنيت وفقا لهندسه المدن والزلازل خاصه بعد
الزلزال الذي ضرب منطقه بحر مرمره في عام
1999 لم تتعرض لاضرار كبيره بكل الاحوال
يقول ان عمليات الانقاذ تسير بشكل جيد
بشكل سلس حتى الان لا يبدو قلقا كثيرا من
هذه الناحيه لكن مما يبدو من الارقام التي
اعلن عنها فان هذه الارقام مرجحه للارتفاع
في الساعات القليله القادمه عبد القادر
شكرا لك يا فرح الزمن الصنعود لك حدوث اي
تجديد لهذه